what I basically try to do is understand
human nature how the mind works what
makes us tick what are the patterns of
thought and emotion and motivation that
characterize our species and I focus on
language partly because you can't make a
living out of studying human nature just
do pick a topic you've got to pick
something tractable to study for me it
is has been in language and indeed for
much of my career one little corner of
language namely regularly irregular
verbs and I have my reasons for focusing
on that particular corner I think it
does shed light on larger questions
about what makes the mind work but
language as a general topic is a I think
a good entree into human nature for a
number of reasons its distinctively
human if you're interested in general in
what makes humans unlike mice and birds
language is a pretty good place to start
not only because of language itself the
fact that we make noise with our mouths
in order to get ideas across
but because language has to be
fine-tuned for the kind of thoughts and
the kind of social relationships that
humans want to share and negotiate with
one another so it's a it's a window into
human nature it's also figured in
debates on human nature perhaps most
famously with Chomsky in the late 50s
using language as a way to rehabilitate
the idea of innate mental structure
something that was virtually taboo in
the 1950s he said language is a very
good candidate for something that is
innately and uniquely human
so it's an opening wedge for the idea
that that important parts of the mind
are innately structured it's also a
prime case of mental computation it's
very hard to make sense of language of
our ability to string words into new
combinations sentences that other people
have never heard before but can very
quickly understand for the first time
without appealing to the idea that we
have a mental algorithm
a set of rules or a recipe or a formula
that picks words out of a memory store
and strings them together in
combinations where the order as well as
the choice of words is meaningful so
language sheds light on the idea that
the mind is a computational system
my main preoccupation today is using
languages as a window into human nature
I've studied language in the past as a
an example of human computation what are
the kinds of simple operations of lookup
and combination that the mind is capable
of how is language structured what I'm
turning to now is the interface between
language and the rest of the mind how
language can illuminate our social
relationships for example why is so much
of language use veiled or indirect or
done via innuendo rather than people
blurting out exactly what they mean why
do I say if you could pass the salt that
would be great instead of give me the
salt why does someone make a sexual
overture in terms of would you like to
come up and see my etchings rather than
do you want to have sex
why are threats so often veiled nice
story you got there would be a real
shame if something happened to it
given that the listener knows exactly
what the speaker had in mind it's not
only anyone is fooled by the charade but
nonetheless some aspect of the social
relationship seems to be preserved if
the request is slipped in between the
lines I'm interested in what that says
about human relationships about
hypocrisy and taboo also what it says
about the kinds of relationships we have
like dominance versus intimacy and
commonality versus exchange and
reciprocity just to be concrete why do
you say I if you could pass the salt
that would be great well in issuing an
imperative you're kind of changing the
relationship you're turning it into one
of dominance you're saying to a friend
or to a stranger I'm going to act as if
I can boss you around and presuppose
your compliance you may not want to move
the relationship in that direction at
the same time you want the damn salt so
if you say if you could pass the salt
that would be great it's such a non
sequitur that the intelligence of the
listener can figure out that it really
is a request but both of you know that
you haven't actually turned the
relationship into a superior inferior I
think that's the key to understanding
all of these that the sexual overture
the veiled threat the veiled bribe and
so on are ways of preserving one of
several kinds of relationships at the
same time as we transact the business of
life such as requests such as sexual
overtures that might be inconsistent
with the relationship that we have with
the person so it's in a way using
language as a way of doing social
psychology
also interested in the effective memory
on language why is so much language
metaphorical not in terms of poetic
ornamentation we don't even realize that
they're metaphorical we said say
something like he moved the meeting from
three to four we're using the metaphor
of time as as a line as a spatial
dimension of a meeting as a thing and
rescheduling as causing motion if we say
I had to force myself to be polite we're
without realizing it using a metaphor of
our natural inclination as inertia a
change in inclination as the application
of force and indeed as conflicting
tendencies as different objects or
people inside our skull being shoved
around it's almost hard to find an
example of language that's not
metaphorical so what does it say about
the human mind does it say that we
actually can never think abstractly that
deep down we always have little cartoons
in our head of Huck's being slid around
on the ice or or people shoving each
other inside the skull or does it mean
that we really do think abstractly but
that deep in the midst of history when
the first coiner of expressions like
force so and so to be nice or move a
meeting came about they needed some kind
of love verbiage and so they cooked up a
metaphor on the spot better than saying
glorg you can say force because least
some people might have some chance of
knowing what you're talking about but
ever since we've been repeating the
metaphor dumbly and we really do think
abstractly that's an interesting
question about what makes us tick
inspired by language and I'd like to get
some insight into it